i mean seriously right now honestly
the happiest chef in the world
[Music]
right welcome to the most amazing farm
um now they said italian truffles are
the best but let me tell you
croatia has some of the best truffles
anywhere in the world i'm in
this beautiful setting and a family run
farm
pardon a stunning location up here in
the mountains
and just just take a look at these
they're not truffles
they are truffle rocks they are boulders
i'm going to keep it simple because when
you've got ingredients like that trust
me
you don't need to complicate anything so
crank this thing up
i'm going to slightly toast a sort of
day old baguette
i'm going to get a little bit of heat in
there fresh pressed olive oil
so i don't want to burn that just get it
going really
super hot lightly season the oil
okay and then from there just take your
bread
and look start mopping up
that incredible seasoning now
i want to toast that bread the eggs
i've made scrambled eggs before but
never quite with
such an amazing abundance of beautiful
truffles
the produce locally here is second to
none
not only do we have the most amazing
truffles but most amazing goat's cheese
as well
pretty incredible eggs in as always no
seasoning okay
we're gonna season it at the end we'll
use this creme fraiche
a little bit of a nice firm ghost cheese
and this is incredible because it gives
a really nice
seasoning just
bring the eggs together i don't want to
beat them too hard in there
the secret of using truffles is slicing
the truffles
super thin and making sure they go over
that nice hot
scrambled egg now i've got
that's what i want in there
that sits in there okay turn that down
and then as that's literally cooling
down there
shave some of that cheese on there okay
and just leave that to sit there
now from there
look at that it's like a paddle and a
canoe the paddle's that big because the
truffles
are that big and look at it i mean
stunning
take my huge boulder okay
thank you the dogs are upset because i'm
using their prized assets
and just slice
the truffle super thin
on there now if i get this really nice
and wafer
okay that starts to permeate the bread
oh my lord beautiful just a little touch
of oil spatula
butter goes in now okay about four
nice little knobs of butter in with the
eggs
okay beautiful
and the secret here is literally
cranking up the heat and just like we
would do on a gas stove
we sort of fold this back in as you can
see
we're cooking on a bit of a hill so it's
all lopsided
nothing wrong with that at all now hit
that
into the middle no seasoning yet okay
and then just keep on beating that back
that butter's melting
it's making the scrambled egg nice and
rich the smell of those truffles are
amazing
now i'm going to start with my seasoning
okay if i season too early
it's gonna turn it gray but look what's
happening
it's coming together beautifully and now
gently on the salt really gently
and then from there in
pepper and then a little touch of my
creme fraiche
in the middle that's going to make the
scrambled eggs
really nice and creamy it stops it from
overcooking
and look and why it's coming to the end
there like that
take your beautiful rock
and just thinly shave
the truffles in there oh boy
and then fold that in there again
okay and
turn that in boom correct the seasoning
before it comes out otherwise mama's
going to kick my ass
touch the salt beautiful
and then low
hmm
and then finally my beautiful
amazing salty delicious
amazing cheese and then the rock
comes back just at the end
and there you go that has to be the most
amazing truffle scrambled eggs
set in the most beautiful countryside
anywhere in croatia
harvested by the most gorgeous family
bona potito now if you enjoyed that
recipe please click the link below and
if you missed uncharted
then please watch it on catch up on
disney plus
[Music]